Let's go to the phone lines and hear what's
on people's minds.
Today, we are taking calls via discord at
David Pakman dotcom slash discord.
Let's start today with Caleb from Atlanta,
Caleb from Atlanta.
You are.
You're on the air.
What's going on?
I did, and I was wondering what your thoughts
are on the future of the guess political discourse
in this country, it seems like Donald Trump
has really just.
Made everyone like.
They're unable to just talk about anything
nowadays, and I was wondering if there's any
recovery from this or the future of, I guess,
conservatives more generally.
Yeah, it's really going to depend.
It's going to depend on two things.
The Republican Party is going to have to decide
whether the coarsening and debasement of the
discourse that happened under Donald Trump,
whether they want to keep things that way
or not.
Now, if you go back to the George W. Bush
era, there was a hell of a lot of debasing
and coarsening of the discourse then, but
it was nothing compared to what we saw under
Donald Trump, you know, mocking disabilities.
And I mean, I don't have to give you the full
list.
You know, it of course, I think that the left
also has a role to play in the sense that
the left could make a stronger stand about.
We are just not going to accept some of this
very base way of talking about politics as
valid.
And we're just not going to engage in it.
But I have I worry that that could have the
backfire effect that the right will say the
left doesn't want to hear any ideas that are
different than their own.
But I think that, unfortunately, a lot of
this depends on whether the Republican Party
says we have to step up the level of debate
a little or whether they you know, if they
perceive that they benefit from the way Donald
Trump has debased the discourse, then they
may continue.
They may decide it's good for them.
Yeah, definitely.
Thank you.
Thanks for your time.
All right, Kayla, I'm going to let you go.
Sounds like you've got a lot going on there,
but I do very much appreciate you calling
in.
Always great to hear from folks all over.
Let's go to Dwayne from Buffalo, New York.
Dwayne from Buffalo, you're on the air.
Dwayne from Buffalo, police unmuted yourself,
you were on the air and you could be speaking
to me right now, if only you unmuted yourself.
Can you hear me, David?
Yes, I can.
Hey, how's it going?
Good.
Yeah, I just wanted to call in and say, you
have an intellectually stimulating show, listen
to you and Kyle Kolinsky and yeah, just keep
up the good work.
You really you're doing a good job and making
people think very hard about what's going
on in society.
Keep it up.
I appreciate that.
So, OK, so you watch The David Pakman Show,
you listen to Kyle, what else is in your media
diet, so to speak?
Uh, New York Times, local news.
Unfortunately, CNN and MSNBC sometimes just
for fun.
I'll take a quick peek at Newsmax and one
American news.
But I'm not really obviously, I don't listen
to that seriously.
And from the standpoint of independent left
wing media, is there anything else in addition
to to Kyle?
Not really.
The young Turks, of course, but I don't really
listen to them as much as I listen to you
guys, but I still do my independent research,
you know, and corroborate things to make sure
that I'm getting a full world view of everything.
Well, it sounds like you're making every effort
to have a, well, well-rounded diet.
Is that what what's the scene in Buffalo in
terms of masks and virus guidelines right
now where Kobe cases have been going up pretty
sharply here, especially where I am, but hopefully
the political leaders get everything under
control, you know, especially with the vaccine
right around the corner.
I'm really looking forward to that.
But, you know, you still have occasional people
without masks and stuff when you go to the
grocery store.
Oh, are they allowed inside without masks
in some cases?
Interesting.
Wow.
All right.
Very good.
Well, I appreciate hearing from you.
Yeah, you too.
Thanks, David.
All right.
There's a D'Wayne from Buffalo coming in with
some some nice some nice praise, I would say.